[موسيقى]
هناك نحو 100 قضيه مرفوعه ضدي وهذه
القضايا تشمل مزاعم التحريض والتجديف
والارهاب وحتى قضايا قتل حيث اتهموني بقتل
شخص كل هذه القضايا وراءها دوافع سياسيه
لابعاد عن سباق الانتخابات فالمشكله هي ان
المعارضه تعرف تماما انها لا تستطيع الفوز
بالانتخابات ومن بين الانتخابات الفرعيه
التي يبلغ عدد مقاعدها 37 فزنا بثلاثين
منها فهم قلقون لان مشاركتنا في انتخابات
الثلاثين من ابريل ستتسبب في هزيمتهم
ولانهم يخشون الهزيمه فهم يحاولون ابعاد
عن السباق من خلال توجيه كل هذه القضايا
ضدي
[موسيقى]
القضيه سببها التظاهر السلمي خارج مفوضيه
الانتخابات وهذا ما يحدث في الديمقراطيات
كلها اتهموني بالارهاب بينما كنت جالسا في
منزلي وعندما حذرت المحاكم بسبب القضايا
التي حضرها عدد كبير من انصاره اتهموني
بقضايا ارهاب اخرى والجميع يعرف تماما
انني خلال خمسين عاما لم اخرق القانون
ابدا انا الشخص الوحيد الذي يثق به الشعب
وبامواله لقد جمعت اكبر كميه من الاموال
في باكستان وادير اكبر المؤسسات الخيريه
في البلاد
ومستشفيين وجامعتين وكلها للفقراء لان
الشعب يثق بي ولا احد يصدق المزاعم
الوارده في القضايا المرفوعه ضده
[موسيقى]
هذا ما يحاولون القيام به هم يفبركون
قضايا الاعتقال لنرى ما سيحدث لدي امل
بالمحكمه العليا وبالقضاء ولكنني مستعد
ايضا في حالته الاعتقال يوما ما وهم كادوا
يعتقلونني يوم السبت الفائت
[موسيقى]